So this is a concept that we're going to be
able to apply in lots of different settings when we have
infinite hypothesis classes. And this is really the fundamental way that
it's used except usually, there's kind of a more of a
technical sounding definition. This notion of labeling in all possible
ways is usually termed shattering. So this quantity that we're talking
about here, this, this size of the largest set of inputs
that the hypothesis space can shatter, is called the VC dimension.
>> What does VC stand for?
>> VC stands for Vapnik - Chervonenkis which is a
pair of actual people. So that, you know, really smart
insightful guys that put together this notion of a definition
and what they did is they can relate the VC
dimension of a class to the amount of data that
you need to be able to learn effectively in that
class. S, as long as this dimensionality is finite. Even
if the hypothesis class is infiniite. We are going to be
able to say things about how much data we need to learn.
So, that's, that's really cool. It really connects things up beautifully. So, I
think what would be a really useful exercise now is to look at
various kinds of hypothesis classes. And for us to measure the VC dimension.
>> Okay, sounds like fun.